QUENTIN HARDY: I'm
here with Suzanne Frey,
director of security, trust,
and privacy at Google Cloud.
She is responsible for ensuring
we gain our customers' trust
with our extensive transparency,
visibility, and controls.
Suzanne, thanks for taking
the time to be with us today.
SUZANNE FREY: Thank you.
QUENTIN HARDY: So why should
businesses trust Google Cloud?
What kind of commitments do
we make that protects them?
SUZANNE FREY: Google
was born in the cloud,
and we've been
cloud-native since day one.
Now, what does that mean?
That means that we've thought
about security and privacy
in how we build and architect
our data centers, servers,
networks, devices,
and applications.
It's allowed us to move
at the speed of the world
since day one, with respect to
security and privacy threats.
And I think that's super
important for folks
to understand.
We have optimized for the cloud.
QUENTIN HARDY: And how
does that get reflected
in the commitments we make?
SUZANNE FREY: Absolutely.
So we put our money
where our mouth is.
We put all of our commitments
to security and privacy
in contract.
These are binding
documents, as you know,
so that customers
can feel comfortable
knowing that we are committed
to their security and privacy.
QUENTIN HARDY: Now, the
customers still know us
very much as a
consumer company--
strong brand, very
strong consumer presence.
And enterprise
customers sometimes
have a few questions
around that.
Can you give me some
clarity on the differences,
and what exactly happens to
enterprise data, for example?
SUZANNE FREY: So going back
to the cloud-native approach
that we've taken, we've
built a tremendous business.
In fact, there's
seven businesses
at Google with over a billion
consumer users apiece.
And just look at that
track record, standalone.
We bring all of the power
of that track record
to our enterprise
customers, and even more.
We talked about
contracts, but we also
commit to not scanning
your data for advertising.
We commit that you can
take your data with you.
We commit that you have
a right to understand
where your data is being stored,
and your IP will belong to you.
QUENTIN HARDY: And
earlier, when I
was talking with Dan and Rene,
we talked about transparency,
because cloud relationships
aren't like standard packaged
enterprise software
relationships.
We don't sell and leave.
We have to earn it and win
it on this rolling basis,
and also keep people informed
around new features, what's
coming up on the product side.
And they were saying that
the change management
and the training involved makes
transparency very important,
and communications important.
From Google's perspective,
why is transparency important?
SUZANNE FREY: Well,
you put yourself
in the shoes of any CIO or
CSO who is making a decision
to move from on-premise to the
cloud, or even another cloud
provider to ours,
and you really have
to understand, how am I going
to know I am safe and secure?
We believe we earn trust
through transparency.
Knowing what's happening to
your data at any given time,
super critical for
earning that trust.
QUENTIN HARDY:
Security is the sense
that you control your
environment, right?
And the transparency means
you can see and control
as much as possible.
That's the idea
behind that, I guess.
So finally, what
are three things
you'd like viewers to
take from this session?
SUZANNE FREY: Well, we've
touched on all three,
in some capacity.
For example, pillar
number one is compliance.
We're committed to our
customers' compliance, examples
being things like
GDPR and FedRAMP.
We have to be ahead of
the curve with respect
to global compliance
regimes, and we
recognize our compliance is
our customers' compliance.
Two, we're committed
to transparency,
trust through transparency,
and enabling customers
to understand what we're
doing with their data.
And thirdly, we're
committed to control.
You are in control of
your data, and not only
with portability and
things like that, but also
the ability to turn
off services or control
the security of your devices,
or understand which executives
in your organization
should have a security key,
and implement and
enforce that at scale.
So those are the three things--
compliance, transparency,
and control.
QUENTIN HARDY: Suzanne,
thank you for joining us.
SUZANNE FREY: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]